good afternoon everyone I'm here to
introduce this afternoon's panel which
is leveraging distributed energy
resources micro grids and storage for
city resilience quite a large topic but
I'm sure that older panelists table
tackle it we have on our panel today Ron
get avec who is the founder and CEO of
wind stacks we have Ben Morris who's the
director of operations work management
and performance for Duquesne Light
Company we have Chris Murray the senior
Business Development Manager for wgl
energy we have Lydia sue Corrick who is
the director of strategy and marketing
from Siemens we have our board Rose
Simha which who is here as a senior
consultant from West Monroe partners we
have Romeo Winstead who is here for
development engineering from NRG and of
course we have dr. J apt who is going to
be moderating the panel as a professor
from Carnegie Mellon so without further
ado we shall let them kick off well
thank you very much it's it's a pleasure
to be introduced so expertly so first
I'm going to give the audience because
we like a intellectually diverse
audience some definitions distributed
energy resources so de ours is the
specialist column dr is a term that
refers to both hardware and software
connected to the local electric
distribution network and so those
resources can produce power think of
rooftop solar arrays or they can consume
power in a controllable way think of an
air conditioner whose setpoint can be
changed or a freezer at Giant Eagle here
in Pittsburgh where they could be
electric storage like a tesla powerwall
micro grids so a micro grid is a small
group of generators and users of
electricity loads as we call them that
are capable of supplying power to the
users within a defined area
and it can be connected to the grid or
operated on its own so those are the
definitions now everybody is more or
less on the same page what I'm going to
do is ask some questions of the
panelists and then you folks have a way
to put in your questions I've got an
iPad here that those will come up on so
first question to Ben Morris and to
Chris Murray what distributed energy
resources are you seeing now on the
civilian grid Benford do King light and
at a u.s. Navy installation for Chris
Murray so Ben first in that dress I'm
happy to go first thank you Chris so for
Duquesne Light Company Duquesne Light is
the local electric utility serving
Pittsburgh and the surrounding area to
give you a sense of the the size of the
electricity flowing across our system
our peak load was approximately three
gigawatts or three thousand megawatts
which was in June of 2012 so that was a
particularly hot year now if that's the
peak when we think about de are the de
are that we currently have
interconnected to our system is
approximately 18 megawatts so that's
approximately 0.6 percent of the of our
peak electricity that's still relatively
small but what what comprises that that
point six percent of our of our
electrical Rupert essentially is
primarily that the largest de ours is
solar so we have a handful and I mean
literally a handful of larger CHP
installations from different customers
on our system but by far the of those 18
megawatts it's primarily solar today and
the driver behind that is we need to
look back a few years historically but
in about 2010 that there was essentially
no de armor system or no renewables in
2014 there there were approximately
three megawatts and a hundreds of 200
customers with with with solar or
renewables 2016 the beginning of the
year approximately 5 megawatts and the
proximately 300 customers in the past
two years since 2016 we have grown from
5 megawatts to approximately 18
megawatts and from approximately 300
customers to 2100 customers but that's
in two years that that's big growth in
in what we're seeing for de are and the
drivers for that it's actually quite
easy to put your finger on in in 2016 we
had some some national entrants for for
solar developers in particular come to
Pittsburgh and begin marketing here so
those those national level marketers are
really the biggest drivers in the past
two years
of the growth that we've seen in the ER
in Pittsburgh I'm specifically I think
there are two reasons why why they've
developed such a growth one is simply
because they've done door-to-door
aggressive marketing so one is just
education and knowledge but for
customers in the area the second and and
I suspect this is the bigger driver is
that the national lever level solar
developers have financing options for
for their product which before 2016
weren't available in Pittsburgh so in my
opinion it's it's both both the
marketing but probably more likely the
financing options that have driven the
growth that we've seen in the past of
years so it's it's still relatively
small in the grand scheme of the
electricity flowing across our system
less than 1% but but the growth is is
real Ben thank you very much Chris
hi Chris Murray WGL Energy reason I got
the question for the Navy it was prior
to coming to wgl I spent about two years
at the Navy helping build the studio
generation resources for the Navy for
resiliency purposes so I'm gonna give
you two answers to your question what
kinds of D ers does the Navy like they
like resilient dr's
but the more precise answer I'm also
going to give you two answers there last
administration it was all about
renewables specifically solar PV that
was primarily driven by the tax credits
we were trying to move a gigawatt of
knuble solar PV primarily as quickly as
possible to try to take advantage of the
tax credits they got extended we got
more breathing room but that's what was
driving it we had a smattering of solar
or smaller smattering of storage a
smattering of fuel cells a smattering of
other stuff but it's primarily solar now
going to my second answer of my two-part
answer in this administration again it's
all about resiliency resiliency
resiliency and some of the services have
decided to define resiliency in terms of
something that can provide 14 days of
backup power so what that means in a
very agna technology agnostic ways they
don't want diesel gensets
they want on-site resources that can
last 14 days that leaves you with guess
it solar PV and other things like that
where you can have nope supply chain
issues in the business world is called
the supply chain and in the military
it's called the kill chain they don't
want to have a kill chain they want to
have something on-site that you can deal
with so it's primarily gonna be soulard
storage but CHP a little smattering of
that as well some fuel cells again you
have a gas issue but the key word is
resilience Chris that's great answer
thank you so for Romulan what sort of
technology mix do you see being
necessary in order for distributed
energy resources in micro grids to
increase customer reliability and grid
resiliency thanks Jay I really like this
question because it hits on three three
major aspects of micro grids you know
you talked about we're talking about
technology mix we're talking about
customer reliability and we're also
talking about grid resiliency for me
when when I was oh when I look at this
it starts with customer reliability you
start with who your customers are and
when you start thinking about customers
you're thinking about the residential
sector your and as you move up this
market ladder you're thinking about
commercial customers industrial
customers institutional segments that's
key and as you keep moving up this
ladder what you see is the need for
reliability keeps going up it
as a multiplier and the importance of
resiliency also starts increasing based
on the type of operations so I think at
the end of the day I think all of these
people are looking for a reliable
resilient power but the but before we
talk about what that right technology
makes is I would say you have to take a
pause to save for your customer what are
the what are your risk factors what are
your requirements and then talk about
what are you some of your goals and a
lot of these customers are thinking
about being sustainable some some
economics might come into play in terms
of operational savings you might have
other operational metrics all of these
things ultimately in my mind is what
defines that right technology makes so I
mean a classic example would be if you
take a medical center that is that's a
hospital that has serving patients you
have a vivarium maybe or maybe a first
responder emergency site there they all
have the same high level need of
resilient reliable power but when you
drill down the risks associated with it
the actual requirements and the goals
that they have might vary so your
technology and you know there's one
consistent threat though between all of
them when you think about this and
that's the need for energy that is
available to them at all times so in my
mind when you say energy it's not just
electrical energy or it's not just
mechanical energy it's both you have to
consider both in tandem because when you
look at your customers what you see is
these are people who are using both
electrical energy and thermal energy and
for the longest time we've looked at
technology and we've looked at
electrical energy and we know that
aggregating multiple buildings
aggregating multiple loads opens up and
diversifies our options with the type of
generation we can put that put on-site
we could you know you have economies of
scale coming into play you have better
plan load profiles and now if you take
on yet another aspect look at the
thermal
of these systems and layered that in now
your options are even larger now you can
think of having a combined heat and
power system you can think of district
energy systems you can then layer that
on with PV potentially so the technology
options start broadening as you start
thinking of energy not just as
electrical energy but it's electrical
energy and thermal energy and so then
what happens is you have this wide array
of options now available to you you can
have solar you can have energy storage
you can have combined hidden power you
can have thermal energy and all of this
together is what and the right
technology makes at the end of the day
is what clearly meets the requirements
what clearly provides a solution for the
risks that were identified what helps
you get to those targets okay thank you
very much this is for wrong the
Pittsburgh Airport is exploring self
generation options to avoid the kind of
mess that Atlanta got into last December
what can you tell us about where
customers like the airport are going to
be in the near future sure sure so as
Jay mentioned back in December of last
year the Atlanta Airport lost power for
all of their critical systems frankly
and it really sent a jolt through the
entire transportation industry on the
East Coast and you know speaking of
resiliency if you think some of these
navy bases are resilient the the these
modern airports today are have an
amazing electrical the kind of system
backups to the utility grid not only in
traditional generators but CHP and steam
etc in fact it's really layer upon layer
upon layer yet this still happened in
Atlanta so just recently the Pittsburgh
Airport looked at considering right now
and are taking requests for
qualifications for self generation for
those of you in the Pittsburgh area you
probably recall a few years ago that the
airport agreed to fracking and leasing
on the airport property so they
certainly
have an abundance of natural gas out
there - look at that so that's uh you
know you know that I'd like to kind of
introduce the notion of prosumers
which are really our target customers
who customers who are considering
producing storing and consuming their as
much energy as they can and still
working with the grid as either the
primary or a backup source of power us
we're in the wind industry so the past
24 hours has been a great couple days
day for our customers to say the least
but I'll give you a quick example if you
indulge me for a minute we have one
residential customer that's an elderly
couple that I happen to live near the
airport that lost their power for about
three hours last night they happen to
have one of our wind and solar hybrid
systems with storage and to them losing
power is is a matter of life and death
they are both on CPAP machines and they
need they need them to you know to sleep
at night etc and they're deathly afraid
of carbon monoxide from generators as
well so our system was specifically
designed to give them four hours of
backup it had if they lost their power
that's exactly what happened last night
we also had a commercial customer in
Virginia that they got sixty some amount
our winds they lost their utility power
just for half an hour but for a
commercial business that can be very
expensive especially in the trucking
business so they're the storage for them
was designed to really help bridge that
gap and you know if these systems are
designed right as storage costs become
cheaper the these interplay with the
utilities very well and do things that
utilities frankly don't like anyway like
it's people trying to get eliminated
some of the peak demand and demand
charges and things like that because be
if there's excess solar for example
that's generated through the day
and they it can be sent back to the grid
etc so that's that's the kind of thing I
think you're gonna see more and more the
presumption model and you know just to
kind of reinforce the previous group who
talked about how utilities are precluded
from storage in some regulatory
environments I frankly also agree that
that's ready for a regulatory overhaul
because folks like Duquesne Light who
are more progressive in embracing these
types of technologies even in pilots
would be excellent partners for these
businesses I don't think many of them
don't necessarily want to do this and
maybe a 7 10 15 year ROI isn't fantastic
for their balance sheets so I think if
there's a platform to help utilities you
know embrace storage that's that's a way
to go
thank you Ron that's great not for euros
New York avoided a billion dollars worth
of grid investments in Brooklyn Queens
by turning to demand management and
local generation and they also want to
avoid problems like they hit after
Hurricane sandy when the next sandy
comes what can you tell us about New
York's reforming energy vision so
reforming the energy vision is sort of a
initiative that was started by Governor
Cuomo back in 2014 and the idea is that
we need to have a clean affordable and
resilient Network hurricane sandy came
in 2012 and really last left the whole
city and in Africa eastern seaboard
devastated New York City the subways
were completely flooded Bellevue
Hospital had to be evacuated and many
others so what we're trying to do in New
York is figure out what kind of solution
can help offset the traditional
investment in distribution in June so in
Brooklyn Queens specifically
Consolidated Edison the utility company
that is in charge of New York City and
metropolitan area they forecasted that
69 megawatts of power
needed in a 10 years time and obviously
traditional way would be to put in
another transformer but another
substation put new cables in line and
that is that 1 billion or 1.2 billion
dollar investment that would be needed
in traditional infrastructure now
majority of the folks here in the room
understand that the distribution as well
as transmission infrastructure is sized
for the hottest day of the hottest hour
of the hottest day in a year so majority
at the time that that infrastructure is
being unutilized so perhaps there is a
better way of instead of putting a new
substation in place a better way to
solve this issue and again hit on all
three points which is again clean
affordable and resilient so non wire
alternatives or non NWA's is how New
York is calling it or if if you ask
somebody else that Straight Outta
Compton and it would be non wireless
solutions instead of NWA we're looking
at all sorts of distributed energy
resources demand response energy
efficiency any kind of way so we can dis
sort of decrease the load and has
perhaps not even built that substation
so that 1 billion dollars is being
offset it by 200 million dollars worth
of investment again in these clean
potentially renewable distributed energy
resources that are being built across
Brooklyn and Queens neighborhoods in in
New York so it's not just content that
is doing that as a matter of fact it's
to reforming the energy vision all
utilities in New York State are mandated
to take a look at how NWA or MW s can be
used instead of traditional
infrastructure so what you do instead of
a typical pilot project or a
demonstration project you take that
money that was already allocated within
the capital investment plan for that
substation
get out of that plan and you spend that
money wisely on an on wire alternate and
by the way we don't know yet if these
non wire alternatives wouldn't be able
to last as long as a transformer which
has what 40 50 years lifetime typically
we don't know yet if solar and storage
can withstand that many years but at
least were we're sort of deferring that
need for capital and investing for let's
say 10 years or 20 years or however long
this technology can last on top of that
we're seeing that load that forecast
might change in that 10-year period and
at the end of that 10 year period we're
gonna do another benefit cost analysis
see if there's still a business case for
a non wire alterius or perhaps will
indeed have to invest a billion dollars
into building out the grid gee that's
well that's that's very interesting new
information indeed I think for many of
us
so for Olivia your company Siemens has
recently formed a joint venture with AES
to provide energy storage solutions what
can you tell us about the business case
that you folks see for energy storage in
the air future thanks Jay so probably
the main question really is addressing
the business case for affluence or
Siemens and AES energy coming together
to perform this venture but it is
largely driven by the business cases of
our customers so I think it's important
to examine you know where where is the
market for storage out there to start
with right so the vast amount of storage
that has been deployed is being the
wholesale or the utility if you look we
would like to call utility side
deployment the projects that are visible
the volume of the projects that a es
storage has deployed really was driven
by contracts with utilities customers
and whether you look at the projects
like the Australian large-scale power
plant or the California one the great
the theme that emerges really
is the flexibility and the versatility
of what storage can provide for those
customers and and when I say that and if
you go to a storage conference you'll
hear very colorful descriptions of you
know storage is the Swiss Army knife of
the electricity sector and and it's like
bacon everything is better with storage
right so why is that right I mean it
truly can help utility defer and the
investment it can help provide the
capability to whether you need fast and
flexible generation either capacity or
energy if you're looking at ancillary
services AES is also now demonstrating
digital inertia for example for systems
that don't have a lot of rotating
equipment there you really can do
anything and everything but what has
really beneath it to me kind of
interesting and important is to look at
this investment theme on the large-scale
storage deployment aside and and the
theme that emerges is that you can build
a whole lot really fast and that really
matters for for capital investment so
that's one side on the behind the
leaders side and I when I think about
this I I can't not think about the
global aspect of deploying anything any
technology that we work with because
we're a global company and I work with
with our colleagues that are across the
world behind a meter the largest driver
for a long time was reducing demand
charges and us has only a handful of
markets where where that has worked
really well with CNI customers but if
you look at UK or any other market that
has multi-tiered and very large spread
of electricity prices you that is that
is a really quick return on investment
and it will be even quicker as the price
is dropping when it comes to a lot of
the projects that were involved in they
are all hybrid projects there are very
few cases where you know there's
standalone storage application for a
number of reasons whether it's cost or
tax credit advantage but really it's
about what does it do right and I think
that for a long time the community
talked about revenue stacking so
different ways of utilizing storage
electricity
kid I think we talked about that less
and less partly because of the modes of
using the battery and when it needs to
be available how to be managed but also
because storage is dropping and writes
when I think about solar contracts BPA's
and when we had you know inverter
reserves years ago because inverters
were very very expensive you know it's
not an issue anymore
you can replace it very cheaply we'll be
able to do the same thing with batteries
now those who are selling to the
end-users of batteries what is their
business model going to be right of
course you can sell the batteries the
question of course is how do you make
money I think it's not a secret that
those who have very large pipeline of
projects are very competitive in the
market so the Tesla's and AES is of the
world or influence it now
just the sheer that the sheer control of
the supply chain is something that
really matters but that's really only
one side of it the other side of it is
also how do we package and how do we
then control these systems and so the
theme that emerges and that is not has
been less of an issue in large-scale
projects but I think in smaller scale
projects is going to be this overhead
beyond the battery price it's only one
third of the system costs right so if
you follow the debate and solar
photovoltaics distributed solar for a
long time you know the soft costs of
implementing solar there's going to be a
whole lot of that and so what are the
advantages and what are the solutions
that can help you become more compact
competitive in smaller scale storage I
think are very endemic to the customer
and the market that you're addressing
and and I could talk about that for
weight really really a long time but
here's an example of something where
Siemens brought a very unique advantage
to fluence and and because AES was not
dealing with storage other than very
large scale batteries in the utility
segment is the very fast startup of the
batteries and so we're talking about few
milliseconds that can really
differentiate you know the kind of
backup that a certain customer might
need depending on critic
of the power another theme that emerges
I think is also because the technology
has been dear risk at this point and is
also becoming cheaper more commonplace
the financing is a lot easier so we're
going to see third-party ownership being
being available and certainly is
available right now with fluence as an
example but that is also going to be in
the mixed with outright ownership of the
batteries for a very long time so the
management and the de-risking of the
operation of the battery then is going
to be a core competency for the business
that's this financing it thank you so
much that's great
then Duquesne Light is proposing to
develop a pilot project micro grid at
your operation center on the North Shore
for resiliency and long term outage
mitigation can you describe that project
a bit for us and also the regulatory and
legislative aspects that you folks need
to make that go absolutely Jay thank you
and and I think we'll actually tackle
the question in Reverse so maybe
starting with what we're trying to
accomplish at a bigger scale
- so within Pittsburgh that the our our
customers but also at the local
government are our have a strong
interest in resilient sport for their
operations and for their activities so
what what do cane light company
ultimately is attempting to do is to
move forward the implementation of micro
grid technology within the Greater
Pittsburgh area there are different ways
that we can do that and say well I'll
share with you what we're trying to
accomplish an app um to explain that I'm
going to draw one distinction which is a
micro grid which is behind the meter and
serving a single customer and a micro
grid that would be in front of the meter
on the greater utility grid and serving
multiple customers when we think about
Duquesne Light companies woods run micro
grid
Jack I'll explain that the details of
the project momentarily but but I'd like
to be clear that it's a behind the meter
micro grid on Duquesne Light company's
own property and the purpose of that is
is resilience resilience of our own
operations campus which to describe the
campus it's approximately 18 acres seven
buildings it has our most critical
operational activities there from the
operation of the grid itself to to the
deployment of the crews that would
restore power to downtown Pittsburgh
if power to be lost in an extended
regional grid failure so for for our
projects and I'm actually not going to
describe it as a pilot project J because
it's its owner and property so do you
gain like company like any other of our
customers has the right to install a
micro grid behind the meter on their own
property that's what we're trying to do
with the woods run micro grid it's it's
we're trying to protect our campus in in
order to protect downtown Pittsburgh
from a prolonged outage before I get in
the legislation I will pause to explain
what what our micro grid looks like so I
describe the campus itself eighteen
acres seven buildings Duquesne Light
company's primary primary operational
activities I'm on that campus the way
that we're constructing our micro grid
is conceptually we have a distribution
ring that encircles the campus and goes
to each of those buildings and then in
terms of the ER we currently have a we
have three diesel generation units that
are interconnected to individual
buildings they are not currently
interconnected to a ring so they can't
serve all seven buildings so what we're
trying to do from a resilience
perspective is the diversity to
diversify those fuel sources I'm
specifically what we're doing is to
install centralized natural gas
generation of 2.5 megawatts which is
sufficient to serve the whole campus
which will add fuel diversity for the
diesel with with diesel typically the
fuel is stored on-site for natural gas
generation it's brought in by pipeline
so it's fuel that's off-site presently
we're looking at a small amount of wind
resources but but we're not looking at
renewable generation in a big way yes
however we are designing the project so
it could be incorporated at a later date
it's it so the one thing that I forgot
to mention so 2.5 megawatts of
centralized natural gas generation we
also have an equal amount of 2.5
megawatts of battery energy storage
systems and that size is sufficient to
carry the entire campuses load for
approximately 5 minutes that's not long
at all the sole purpose of those couple
of minutes is to smoothly transition
from having the campus being grid
connected I'm too isolating into
islanded mode so in a nutshell the micro
grid is 2.5 megawatts of natural gas
generation
I'm 2.5 megawatts of battery energy
storage for it for 5 minutes and a micro
grid controller to tie it all together
so that that's the project and again
that that's a a regulatory project we're
seeking recovery of that through the
existing regulations on our own property
as a facilities project essentially
we're protecting our facilities just
like any of our other customers now
looking forward where we'd like to go
and where our customers and and the city
would like us to go is to build micro
grids on the broader distribution route
grid where we can protect multiple
customers in critical areas like the
downtown Oakland hospital district or
water treatment facilities critical
community infrastructure assets in order
to get there what we're attempting to
you with our pure utilities in
Pennsylvania is to introduce legislation
at the state level and specifically
House bill 1412 which is a House bill
that that's proposing that utilities
electric utilities in the state can
implement utility owned micro grids in
front of the meter serving multiple
customers so currently that that House
bill has been voted out of the veterans
and emergency preparedness committee at
the state legislature level um it will
go before the broader legislature this
year hopefully and should it pass
Duquesne Light Company would then
propose pilots that are in front of the
meter and more in line with what the
city and our customers are looking for
us to bring to protect broader
Pittsburgh um that's where we are
perfect that's great I really appreciate
that then so for Chris I'd like to ask
you what do you see is the economics of
micro grids and there's a question from
the audience closely related that says
what's the main roadblock to micro grid
deployments they're expensive what's the
main roadblock they're expensive I told
you they were closely related questions
so economics in the in there in an ideal
world you can make money you can save
money you can have increased resilience
much might have which might allow you to
save money which I'll explain and then
it might just look good for your
branding and marketing for
sustainability purposes so let me
explain with regard and make money
Lidia already kind of mentioned it
sometimes if you have a micro grid that
has a battery and maybe it's connected
to solar or maybe it's connected to gas
whatever it's connected to it has
resources that you can use and as access
resources that you can bid into a
wholesale market so you still have
enough energy on-site to maintain
resiliency insight but you have an
access that you can provide for instance
in PJM may be providing frequency
regulation that's a nice and I've in the
places I've worked actually actually not
peak shaving or peak demand charges that
are actually not making any money on
that it's ancillary services can help me
finance a project so that's the make
money part terms of the save money a
couple different things if I have solar
and maybe gas combined with a battery
behind the meter and I'm in a high
priced part of the country maybe I'm in
the Northeast I'm going to be able to
sell that commodity it's
you the end-use customer and a lot
cheaper rate than they are going to be
able to get it from the grid so instead
of paying 12 cents in New England maybe
they're only paying 6 cents from the
behind the meter so they're gonna save
on the commodity they're gonna save also
because maybe they have a big operation
on campus maybe they've got lots of
generation already built on campus
because they've got fancy stuff for
instance there's a campus in d.c fda's
white oak campus they do a lot of
research there they can't let the
electricity go down they there's certain
things that probably shouldn't get
unfrozen diseases and other things so
they got to make sure that they have
absolute resilience at all times
and never go down they don't have a
battery on-site if I put a battery
on-site I'm like actually be able to
optimize this system so I don't have to
do spinning reserves I'm gonna save them
money also if I'm going to a corporate
customer they're thinking I gotta build
a big building I've got to build the
walls and the lighting and I've gotta
build all the boilers and chillers and I
say wait a second you don't have to do
the energy infrastructure at all I can
buy that I can element operate it and
maintain it that hundred million dollars
you're gonna spend on that big campus
maybe I can shave off 10% of that maybe
that is my capex in my op X and then I'm
building that into the rate that they're
paying so maybe they can save money by
thinking about a micro grid differently
because they're not doing the capex op x
so resilience maybe they're our
manufacturing facility and if they have
a little blip or maybe it's a research
facility and they have a little blip
they have to throw all that stuff away
if it's Big Pharma they're throwing
those pills away if it's a Navy research
facility they're taking literally
research projects go for two years
straight get a little blip if you gotta
throw it in the trash and start all over
so a little bit of resilience he's gonna
save his staff time money and lost
product maybe you're a corporation and
you want to show that you have our green
the way you do it
typically in old school is let's buy
some racks let's show that we're doing
green energy well what if you had the
micro grid behind
you know maybe you had solar behind the
meter maybe you're thinking about your
sustainability play and a lot broader
way it's not just buying recs but it's
producing clean renewable resilient
energy behind the meter and saving money
in the bottom line to help you then
build your micro grid so that is the
business case in the world world which I
still have yet to see and try that's
great so um let me incorporate one of
the questions from you folks in a
question furro Mia during sandy the
natural gas grid stayed up in a lot of
places not all places you folks have a
one point four megawatt fuel cell in
Bridgeport and you've also got a smaller
fuel cell pilot project coming in here
what can you tell us about those
projects at the University of Bridgeport
in Connecticut we have a 1.4 man
megawatt molten carbonate fuel cell
essentially it's a unit that in addition
to providing electrical power also
recovers heat it recovers about 2.2 mm
BTUs of hot water it's it's again it
comes down to the size of the system and
the load profiles that the university
sees this this fuel cell is able to
carry about 80 percent of the campus
loads the heat that's recovered gets
used as hot water in three of the
buildings that are on site so overall
the the sizing of the system worked
perfectly with the loads that were there
at the University now in addition to
that what we decided to do was
incorporate the loads that were existing
identify what the critical loads are
bring in a control of bringing controls
for load management and create a system
on-site create a distribution system
on-site that allows this unit to island
itself if it sees instability on the
grid so that's where I think
traditionally it's a base load operation
that runs 24/7 it helps the university
supplement some of its energy needs and
on the other hand if there is a critical
this is a great disturbance or there are
storms or something passing through the
season it seamlessly transitions and
Islands itself and powers all of the
critical facilities so that was one area
where we started working with fuel cells
and we started at understanding what
some of its characteristics were and so
we extrapolated that into looking at
other kinds of fuel cell technologies
molten carbonate being one of them that
we'd seen solid oxide fuel cells were
another one we were interested in and so
right now we're piloting a 200 kilowatt
much smaller than the 1.4 megawatt unit
out at Bridgeport just two more
kilowatts at the North Shore NRG Energy
Center right here in Pittsburgh the idea
here is that we want to tie it to our
existing plant we generate steam and
chilled water now this would be a
supplement to be about and another
source of energy on-site and essentially
it's a five thousand our pilot project
which we're working with fuel cell
energy and to do even thank you very
much so I'm gonna ask for one minute
answers for the next three questions if
I can
all right let me start with reject can
you describe how Siemens sees the
distributed energy resource landscape
evolving in the near future so there's
um I think the question actually
probably warrants beyond Siemens the
evolution of the system um I think that
the trend actually of digitalization of
these resources is incredibly important
it is when we hear and talk about and
read about the energy as a service
including micro grid as a service
implementation when you actually read
what that is mostly talks about
financing micro grids but if we can
imagine being able to operate and manage
whether your utility that owns micro
grids behind or front of the meter or a
customer who doesn't want to have to
deal with having to optimize their
systems and in
things trying to reduce RNN I mean that
is also another big driver that is an
ability that is going to be very very
easily accessible but it's not a routine
offering in the field quite yet I have a
few other thoughts but we have only one
minute so thank you so much appreciate
it
Horace we have seen some proposals for
deferring capacity like the growth
brooklyn-queens what projects that
involve capacity deferrals do you see
that have positive economics so that
really depends on the location again
there in Brooklyn Queens it made sense
because it was a 1.2 billion dollar
traditional investment if we're talking
about upstate New York or any rural area
where land is cheap and you can put a
couple extra poles and now there it's a
transformer in there it might not make
sense again what we've seen really work
very well is again energy storage why
because it indeed can operate in the
wholesale market frequency response
voltage support and especially if it's
coupled with the solar so it has access
to that investment tax credit and the
mine floor has to be charged by that
solar at least 75% of the time that
really is a combination that we see
working in a lot of places well thank
you my iPad timer says we have one
minute so Ron can you tell us where you
see community silver going in one minute
no I you know positive or negative yes
yeah you know just to use another quick
example we're working with a
post-traumatic stress syndrome veterans
retraining Center in Arizona that is a
more or less an off-grid community that
they have a number of residences about
50 of them
and they're learning skills while
they're only through rehabilitation
which include solar and alternative
energy wind sustainable farming and
other things so this is a situation
where we're putting in a high voltage DC
micro grid a one megawatt battery
storage system completely wind and solar
that happens to be off-grid south of Las
Vegas so we do get quite a few inquiries
about that so and in other major users
like indoor agriculture we're seeing
more and more of the thoughts of not
energy as a service but energy as an
investment which is a different
philosophy in in our group well thank
you all very much and I hope that the
panelists have given you all an idea of
the breadth and really vibrance of de
ours and micro grids in the current
climate so please let's thank our
panelists
[Applause]